io ricordo
quando ero ragazzino ogni tanto
al telefono si prendevano due coppette
vuote di gelato si metteva un filo in
mezzo uno parlava e l'altro ascoltava
poi quelli più avventurosi provavano ad
aggiungere coppette da aggiungere fili
si scopriva che se tu legga vi il filo
in un certo punto l'altro sentiva se lo
legava in un altro non sentiva se
mettiamo un certo numero di coppette
funzionava se mette un numero diverso
non funzionava soltanto tanti anni dopo
quando ho cominciato a capire le onde
quando mi hanno parlato di segmento
aureo di serie di fibonacci ho capito
quelle cose ma allora era pura magia
erano telecomunicazioni fatte in casa
chiaramente arrivavano soltanto in un
certo ambito non erano come le
telecomunicazioni di oggi che
raggiungono i quattro angoli del mondo
un mondo che rotonde che non ha angoli
quindi capita anche la complessità di
fare queste cose
in generale non ce ne accorgiamo che
sono complicate perché sono nascosto non
ne vediamo ma se soltanto andassimo a
passeggiare per le strade di hanoi o in
qualche paese del sud america o in
africa
vedremo delle matasse di fili
impressionanti allora ti viene in mente
di sì cribbio ci sono queste
infrastrutture guarda come sono
complicate e non solo capiresti anche
che aggiustare queste cose deve essere
una cosa complicatissima e guardate
questo signore che si arrampica in mezzo
a questi fili e credo debba trovare
quello giusto per riuscire a fare le
cose che deve fare
eppure ci sono delle reti che sono molto
più complicate di queste reti di
telecomunicazioni sono delle reti che
sono nate circa 34 miliardi 3,4 miliardi
di anni fa sono le reti metaboliche sono
delle reti che sfidano quella che è la
seconda legge della termodinamica
cercano di mettere ordine nel caos
un caos pazzesco che c'è nelle nostre
celle cellule che hanno miliardi
centinaia di miliardi di molecole che
che girano attorno a circa 100 miliardi
se togliamo le molecole d'acqua e e qui
tutte queste inconterà connessioni sono
delle cose che devono essere messe nella
catena giusta per poter dare origine a
quel fenomeno che è la vita
no per crescere e moltiplicarsi vivere
ebbene ci sono delle reti che sono nate
molto tempo dopo circa 600 mila
di anni fa e che sono più complicate di
queste sono le reti che abbiamo nel
mondo degli animali quelle che portano
l'informazione nostro cervello e le reti
soprattutto che stanno nel nostro
cervello sono delle reti particolari
perché perché fanno emergere delle cose
che chiamiamo pensieri sensazioni e
quando io parlo chiaramente parlo con le
vostre sensazioni le stimolo magari
parlo coi vostri pensieri ma riesco a
fare qualche cosa di più io riesco a
entrare nel vostro cervello passare da
questa rete di pensieri entrare dentro
nella vostra rete di neuroni
se io vi dico adesso che voi indossate
le scarpe
beh adesso voi sentite che avete i piedi
non è vero quindi sono entrato dentro di
voi cioè c'è questa correlazione e nel
cervello noi abbiamo circa 100 miliardi
di neuroni più 100 miliardi di astrociti
atrocità più la storicità meno e abbiamo
mille miliardi di connessioni
ecco sono questi volumi che portano in
qualche modo anche a partire delle cose
molto semplici come semplice un neurone
tutto sommato portano a questa emergere
dei pensieri a questa consapevolezza
alle emozioni e allora la domanda è ma
io riesco a fare una rete che in qualche
modo abbia anche queste caratteristiche
l'elettronica in questi 60 70 anni di
evoluzione ha fatto due cose incredibili
una è ridurre enormemente quello che è
il componente di base il transistor
siamo partiti nel 47 1.146 devono
transistor a lungo più o meno così è già
vent'anni dopo questi transistor era
diventati talmente piccoli che si
potevano mettere su una cosa che si
chiamava piccolo chip da un pezzetto di
cose e abbiamo continuato a crescere
da una parte ammettendo sempre più
transistor dall'altra riducendo sempre
più le dimensioni fino a quello che
vedete in questo in questo diagramma in
cui il transistor è sceso da questa
nuvola azzurrina degli anni settanta più
grande di una nostra cellula fino a
diventare sempre più piccolo più piccolo
di un globulo rosso di uno spermatozoo
più piccolo di un batterio più piccolo
di un virus nel 2002 i transistor
diventati più piccoli
virus e l'altra magia è stata quella di
far scendere enormemente i costi per cui
è diventato possibile produrre sempre
più transistor perché costavano sempre
di meno e nel 2000 intorno al 2000 siamo
arrivati a produrre circa 100 miliardi
di transistor nel 2009 2010
siamo arrivati a produrre 100 miliardi
di chip 100 miliardi questo numero
tornano ma allora uno si chiede ma va
bene io ho capito che posso avere gli
stessi numeri che abbiamo nella testa
nel nostro cervello e c'era ma riusciamo
a mettere insieme queste cose vediamo
che abbiamo dei transistor qui che vanno
a osservare i neuroni le reti di neuroni
e li misurano quindi ci siamo come come
dimensioni siamo proprio lì ma come
complessità
beh la complessità che noi abbiamo in un
centro tipo quello di un grande data
center di google
la vedete è anche nei sotterranei non
soltanto nei transistor queste è la zona
che serve per rinfrescare per portare
aria fredda raffreddamento ai transistor
ma abbiamo una complessità che ancora
maggiore se andiamo a vedere al di fuori
se andiamo a vedere nelle nostre mani i
cellulari questa è una figura di
cellulari che stati buttati via ogni
giorno in italia buttiamo via 86.000
cellulari 86.000 pensate se noi
riuscissimo a mettere insieme tutti
questi cellulari che tutti insieme hanno
una capacità di memoria di
memorizzazione di circa 200 milioni di
gigabyte che una quantità più grande di
grandi data center che contengono le
informazioni ma è possibile mettere
insieme tutte queste cose deve essere
una cosa estremamente complicata come
diavolo si potrebbe fare beh se voi
guardate queste immagini sono delle
immagini di store di tordi che stanno
volando e vedete che creano delle
architetture delle scenografie
incredibili
è come se ci fosse un tordo più più
bravo degli altri no che fa scenografie
dice guarda tutti esposti di lie to
dispostivi e invece no sono delle regole
semplicissime il tordo cosa sta pensando
in questo momento dice cerchiamo di
stare dietro quello che mi sta davanti
perché così
fatico meno volare e cerchiamo di non
sbattere con quello che ho di fianco
ecco questo è semplice regole danno
origine a questi movimenti enormi noi
stiamo cominciando a capire a fare
queste cose
stiamo cominciando ad esempio a capire
che una macchina può circolare un po da
sola il centro ricerche fiat qui a
trento sta provando a fare delle
macchine che effettivamente guidano da
sole
ora queste macchine hanno un loro mondo
ed è autonomo ma ci sono altre macchine
che in contemporanea stanno guidando
pensate quando ci saranno tante di
queste macchine
ciascuna di queste fa i fatti suoi in
una certa misura ma deve anche capire
che cosa le altre stanno facendo che
cosa faranno
stiamo generando dei sistemi autonomi
paralleli complessi che ci portano
proprio in questa nuova dimensione che è
una dimensione che tutto sommato è
naturale perché questa che vedete qui
rappresenta quella che la mia rete
sociale andata presa sia andata a
prendere su su linkedin
queste reti sociali sono delle reti che
cambiano nel tempo perché se mi capita
di parlare con una persona con una certa
frequenza
e come se stabilisce un contatto molto
più forte tra me e lui o tra me e lei
ebbene queste cose qui cambiano la mia
rete e continua a variare questa cosa si
aggiungono dei nuovi amici sono degli
amici con cui non parlo da moltissimo
tempo ci sono delle conoscenze
occasionali
noi stiamo cercando di sperimentare
queste reti tra cervelli tra teste
proprio qui a trento con lo smart campus
che c'è all'università
utilizziamo le tecnologie per vedere che
cosa succede
quindi siamo già portati sul mondo delle
reti a livello dei cervelli e riusciamo
anche a fare delle cose come quelle che
vediamo qua questa fotografia scattato
nel salotto di casa in cui se paolino il
pp il più piccolo dei miei figli anche
se più alto di me è oramai che mi diceva
che io gli credo
non lo so comunque stava facendo un
compito di latino come lo stava facendo
aveva la tastiera bluetooth collegata a
un ipad che era collegato alla apple tv
a sua volta collegata col televisore in
modo che lui scriveva e vedeva le
scritte di latino comparire sul
televisore poi l'ipad era anche
collegato a un
gately o un modem adsl che lo portava
sul mondo internet per andare a cercare
delle cose e poi aveva un iphone di
fianco con cui tramite facetime
dialogava con i suoi amici
ecco io mi chiedo come facesse cicerone
a fare un compito di latino
di fronte a tutte queste credito ecco
però tutte queste reti qui sono reti
fatte in casa sono reti che non
richiedono una competenza incredibile un
ragazzino di 16 anni si mette li crea la
sua rete
questi ragazzini nel tempo diventeranno
guariranno diventeranno grandi e sarà il
nostro futuro e continueremo a fare
queste reti saranno reti fatte in casa
che andranno per tutto il mondo
veramente siamo tornati al tempo del di
quando ero ragazzino è una cosa
fantastica tecnologica tutto sommato è
ancora magia